what did he say he says he loves you but
he went in a different direction
i'm done i'm quitting acting
i'm driving through the hills i'm sorry
one more time
we got another offer it's a million
bucks it's to attend a wealthy
gentleman's birthday party i absolutely
love this movie i think this might be
one of my top three favorite movies of
all time it's incredible for you how do
you play i've heard that you said that
this was the most difficult character
you've ever had to play and you're
playing two characters so how
challenging is it to play a version of
yourself and play two of them there was
no muscle in my body that told me i
should do a movie where i'm nic cage or
nikki cage it was a challenge because
you know i didn't want to embarrass my
family and i also had to facilitate the
director's needs and he was a fan of
neurotic or backslash anxiety fuel nic
cage said quote that's the best nick
cage end quote
but i also don't feel
that way in my own home life so it was a
balancing act and the other thing is as
an actor we want to
hide behind characters and create
characters you know infuse them with
genuine emotion and and imagination but
it has a different name so
it's much easier to do that when it's
not you but when it is you you feel very
emotionally naked and you feel very bare
and very exposed and that's the way i
felt the entire time making this movie i
was very
i'm still recovering from it it was not
easy i mean it really wasn't but i'm
happy to see that all involved were very
thoughtful and sensitive and we got
somewhere that i think is enjoyable for
everyone i saw the movie in a cinema and
everybody was laughing and just felt so
good and i do recommend people go to the
theater to see it because it is that
communal feeling that we used to have
when we would laugh together and i
recommend i agree i agree because i
think it's one of those films that i'm
going to recommend everybody see because
it is a almost a genre that they don't
make anymore anymore i'm interested that
you said you saw it because i thought
you would say maybe you were never going
to watch it it was going to be a little
bit too meta for you um i'm wondering do
you have so many film references some of
your past film references which one
which day for you was the most sort of
surreal
to to revisit
well
i only
well first of all i had to see the movie
at a certain point because i was a
producer on the movie and the two
elements the director in the studio
started knocking heads and we needed
fresh eyes and i had to look at
everything
take my half my mind have my heart shut
it off look at it from neutral and say
this is not working to the studio and
this is not working and tom and we got
to a place where all of us
were happy but i mean surreal days yeah
well
walking into hobby
pedro was beautiful in the movie it was
a great performance but walking into
javi's chamber of nick cage memorabilia
i would say that was the most surreal
day and looking at a wax statue of
so-called nick cage and saying it's
grotesque and i'll give you twenty
thousand
all of it is so ridiculous and yet so
wonderfully playful but that was a weird
day
i can imagine and i mean i mean i'm
sorry interrupt nikki but when i said
you know it's trippy trippy
cool but trippy uh that's exactly how i
felt
yeah oh my gosh i love it um
which uh which
moment do you think gave you the biggest
super eight feeling you've talked about
having you do roles that give you the
super eight feeling for you gave you
that i'm so happy you brought that up
and the super 8 feeling is when you know
a movie's working and uh the super 8
feeling is what you feel like when you
have a super 8 camera and your kid and
you're making movies in your own
backyard and you're only making movies
because you love acting and you love
story and you're not doing it for money
and you're not doing it for oscars
you're doing it because you love movie
making and i'm having that currently on
a movie called renfield and in this
movie on massive talent i think i had
that super eight feeling every time i
was working with pedro uh i saw kindred
spirit in pedro he's a film enthusiast
we would talk cinema on camera and off
camera so it was like no acting please
it was that super 8 feeling
i really feel like this film is an
homage and a love letter to your fans
and people who have loved your
filmography through the years do you
have a fan encounter that is most
memorable to you either surreal bizarre
or fabulous well i had a i had one last
night that was quite poignant uh
a woman said hello to me and she said
that she uh had lost her daughter sadly
to a car accident in 1997.
subsequently my movie city of angels
came out and she said i just love that
movie because every time i hear alanis
morris's song
and i see the movie it brings me back to
my daughter and keeps my daughter with
me and i thought that was very heartfelt
and poignant and it meant a lot to me
if there was three movies that you would
pair if somebody's going to watch a
nicholas cage marathon and they're going
to pair three of your previous films
with this film which three would you
recommend well
if i'm going to do in terms of pairing i
would want to show the range so i would
say let's do adaptation
and then let's do conair
and then let's do pig that was for a
pairing in terms of
the range and being eclectic but my
three favorite movies would be uh
pig leaving las vegas and bringing out
the dead but i think mandy has a has a
great place there as well as lord of war
oh it just goes on i'm very they're all
my babies they're all my children i care
about all of them i put up my heart and
soul into my characters
if you were to play the javi character
opposite any actor in history if you
could play that person who's playing the
opposite if somebody was playing
themselves who would you choose well
it's funny you mentioned that because i
had that conversation with pedro all the
time i said you know you've got the best
part i'll trade with you right now i
love hobby i love that character
uh if i could play javi
yeah i mean i i've i've been hobby i
mean
i've worn out my welcome with people and
and and tried to
geek out and
but um you know i i would say marlon
brando they're no longer with us john
lennon marlon brando james dean uh you
know it goes on and on and on
the guy that owns this house what's his
name cubby hobby mr casey excuse me is
hobby going to want me to uh you know
i'm not sure i understand look it's
hobby
nick cage it's unbearable it's
unbearable you are so talented and is it
massive is it massive it's massive and
unbearable speaking of bears how amazing
is paddington too
it's so good that was my only homework
for the movie actually it was this was
the movie it was the only movie
reference i needed to polish up on okay
okay so what is your third favorite
movie of all time for people who don't
know what we're talking about they're
just gonna have to see the movie
that is such a good question oh man it's
so hard i i i have i have i have a list
what is my third favorite movie of all
time do you know um
all about eve do you know that movie yes
classic
let's just sit and talk about all about
eve
for the next five minutes um okay so
it's my understanding you grew up
watching nicholas cage movies
super fan
um how many of you actually acted out in
your life how many nic cage scenes have
you acted out in your time
that's such a good question because it
isn't necessarily um acting out specific
performances but having those
performances in your conscience
conscious you know what i mean i can i i
remember having moments where i i don't
even like um you have a reaction in your
head and you say thank you i know that
now and it's like you you you realize
that that's how it sounds in your head
and it takes a minute to be like oh
that's what nicolas cage did in uh
honeymoon in vegas
yeah and i'm always in my head going
thank you i know that now you know
because it's like indelibly marked into
my into my system so i understand that
the first day on set you were a little
bit in your head like it was kind of
surreal that you kind of don't remember
it what was that like and when you act
opposite your heroes does it go the way
you thought it was going to go
you know with him i think that um him
being
such a
great legendary actor one of my
favorites i guess it wasn't a surprise
that he'd be such a good scene partner
which can really anchor you to
the story and to the moment and you know
to the scene
so that helped a lot because i was
really scared and they were i was always
bringing myself back from
the moment of i'm
my scene partner is nicholas cage right
now we're in dubrovnik and i'm shooting
a movie with nicholas cage and and and
he's my i'm i'm acting with him you know
and um and and but he was so good that
it helped me kind of i guess focus in a
way and just be in it with him well you
two are such a good duo and by the way
in my interview with him he talked about
his love for you quite a bit so the love
is very mutual it's very mutual real
quick so your top three favorite cage
movies of all time
okay
so okay wild at heart
adaptation
and uh raising arizona which means that
i have to kill so many of my other
favorites it's not fair i know it's it's
so tough um
so if you and so if javi and nick were
to have a sequel because i think they
absolutely need to have a sequel and
they were going to team up again
and they got to write their own sequel
and bring in another actor to play
himself who are you bringing in as your
third wheel oh my gosh that's such a
good
question
let's see um
who are some of his uh uh
great
co-stars let's get cher
oh my god i love that that's gonna be
great
i so thought you were gonna say harrison
ford because i know you love indiana
jones well yeah harrison ford but we
just kind of like keep it in the world
of nicholas cage movies but then yes if
cher's not available
harrison ford yeah yeah i met another
one um if you i i was starting to think
like did this movie make you think of
what it would be like to sort of play
yourself in a movie and if you did and
you were playing pedro pascal
and you had a scene where you were
playing opposite your younger self as
nick does in this how do you think that
would go
how do i you know i don't even want to
ask that question there were so many
things that i didn't let myself think
about in terms of the position that
nicholas cage felt he was in playing
nick cage i i do know that in seeing the
movie it almost feels like the part that
i play is closer to me as far as being
such a like earnest fan of
him as an actor and also movies in
general that um that that it it could
have been closer to me than than nic
cage was to nicholas cage which of your
scenes would you like to reenact from
one of your previous performances
what do you think would be fun which of
the scenes uh with if from
your own filmography well let's go back
to game of thrones and let me win the
fight officially pick my teeth up off of
the arena
uh which was like a couple of minutes
walk from where we were shooting this
movie unbearable weight of massive
talent in dubrovnik which was full
circle for me
god this place is stunning what is your
favorite movie that's one of those
questions that's impossible to answer
you can't just limit it to one imagine
me and you i do
congratulations this is probably well
going to be one of my top three favorite
movies of all time i'm obsessed with
this
thank you that's so lovely
uh first i wanted to ask you
um i understand in high school you were
already a super fan of nicolas cage and
you used to do something called caging
yeah explain why you loved him so much
and what you used to do i mean you know
for people especially in my generation
national treasure came out you know as
you're growing up and he's always been
you know you can follow his career up
until you start being like cerebral
enough to really appreciate his
performances and i think around that
time was when i started getting into the
caging because you see him and
you know as a young person it's like
mind-blowing you're seeing an acting
style that you've never seen before you
know yeah and the caging did come in i i
it's where you you cut out pictures of
nick and you put them on someone's
locker we had a whole instagram account
for it and we tried to make it like a
whodunit kind of thing and people were
very invested so i i think i i brought
some good me and nick brought some good
to my school at that point but
um he's just amazing i mean i don't know
anyone who who isn't a nick cage fan you
know it's he's fantastic and he's had
such a story career and it's so
impressive to me so
you know i think i'm glad at least that
i had i had good taste when i was
younger so that's good
well one thing i think you got to
experience that a lot of us haven't got
to experience before but we got to do it
in this film is the dad energy that he
brought to this film and i understand
you're now going to have knife throwing
on your resume as one of your special
skills and that he sort of brought that
dead energy to you sort of offset
because this is like your first big role
yeah yeah exactly he was very patient
with me which which was really lovely
and unexpected to a degree he was if i
had any questions or i needed any advice
or help he was incredibly forthcoming
and very
you know he was very open so we had a
lot of downtime on set and we could talk
we could talk about shared interests or
we could talk about you know which was
insane to me it was crazy so
he is such a good i i know he has a
great relationship with his kids in real
life but it really shows through
when he was talking with me he's very
paternal and very protective and and he
was always making sure that i was okay
and that we were all right and you know
in the scenes especially it's very
intimate for for the both of us you know
so yeah we would always kind of check in
and and it was fantastic i mean i i
could go on and on and on but he's he's
like the loveliest person alive
okay so aside from nicholas cage if you
could play the javi character in a
future movie and play opposite any
actress who was playing herself who
would you choose oh god
that is very difficult i immediately i
would say if we could somehow do
elizabeth taylor i would love that that
would be a fantastic that'll be once in
a lifetime but
maybe back in the day like who's afraid
of virginia woolf era that would be very
fun for me
oh my gosh she is amazing okay so we're
asking everybody today if you were gonna
pair this movie somebody was gonna have
a nicholas cage movie marathon and
you're going to pair this movie with
three other nic cage movies what do you
think would go best
three other nick cage movies i would say
number one face off for sure because
you know there's a lot of references
within the movie the guns and everything
that um hmm the second one
i'm gonna go with raising arizona
because of the level the way that the
cohen's did that is you know to a degree
stylized in the same way that this movie
is um so i think that's a good pairing
and then the third one i'm throwing it
in everywhere pig everyone needs to see
pig so i think regardless of how it fits
everyone should see it it's like a life
changer
oh god i love this list okay um i know
in the movie does life imitate art
because in the movie
he's giving you movies you should watch
as a teen and you're like generational
gap it's not working did you actually
recommend a movie for him and did he
recommend a movie for you oh that was my
favorite part of being on set with him
he has the best taste in movies of all
time so he recommended me i'm really
into horror he recommended this amazing
movie audition um that's very twisted so
i would say not a general recommendation
but it's great i mean it's so cool to be
able to be like god i got like a movie
recommendation from nicholas cage it's
amazing so i'm gonna start like pushing
that off i'm gonna coin it as my own
recommendation and give it to other
people as well
[Music]
tom i know you wrote nick a letter sort
of asking him to be in the film how did
you convince him i know he said part of
it was sort of the details of the script
but how do you convince him to be in
this film and were you guys like when
you got the yes because if you didn't
get the yes you were pretty much screwed
yeah we were finished that was it for us
uh you know kevin and i wrote the letter
together actually but we we wrote it and
we were like you know just trying to
express to him our love first of all our
intention was to like celebrate his body
of work and then he's done so many
different genres of film really well
it's different than a lot of different
actors
who lock into a particular thing and we
thought nick this we we said to him this
would be a really great opportunity to
do all the different genres in one film
if we can pull it off and i think the
big if there was you know uh
exciting to him you know it was exciting
to him to to
take on that challenge
any part you were nervous for him to
read
the entirety of the script for doll
pretty much the first thing
yeah the first act really was kind of
the because it's the part of the movie
where he's you know more down on his
luck he's you know struggling to connect
with his daughter so he's got to kind of
play like a a bad dad and so
that was the thought the part where we
went if he can just get past that if he
gets to page 50
where he starts turning into a hero i
think maybe we have a have a shot at
this thing so and thank god he he made
it to the end and here we are
um the line where he says nicholas k
was that
written that way did he do that how many
takes are on the cutting room floor if
you only make him do it once i'll say
this uh
it was written as nick effin cage
exclamation point
nicholas cage came we called action and
we got that okay and we finished and the
entire crew's watching and i take off
the headphones and he walks offset and
comes over to kevin and i and he looked
at us and said
i wanted it to be transcendent
and then he walked away and we were like
that's incredible and he was like you
don't want something else do you we
thought no no no no that's something
you're only getting with nicholas cage
and that's sort of the beauty of of him
as a performer but then he did it like
seven more times yeah he was like that
was that was that was what it was that
was his choice
director's cut it's gotta be in there um
if you are going to pair if you're gonna
take your film and have somebody watch a
movie marathon this film plus three
nicholas cage films which three films
are you pairing with yours
oh interesting i think we have to pair
it with adaptation
right yep
um adaptation face-off and let's call it
moonstruck moonstruck or leaving las
vegas like we want some fashion comedy i
would go the rock oh the wrong okay see
this is the problem there's so many
great nicholas can you keep remembering
one that you're like ah this would be a
you know fantastic version but i think
three different genres is the way to go
okay if you were going to because you
satirize with love so many hollywood
tropes if you were going to satirize a
hollywood junket interview what would
you do
who's playing me uh okay well yeah
yeah i would i yeah how would we
satirize a hollywood junket jesus
yeah it's
yeah it's tough
well we're trying to find a level of uh
i'm i'm truly enthusiastic every for
every interview i know tom's kind of
plain character he's miserable
uh on the inside but uh yeah my love is
real yeah i think i would show you like
how much like we're falling apart over
here you know
sweating
if the studio said to you you have to
make a sequel
and you have to choose a new actor who's
going to play themselves it's really
tough but who would you choose
oh man i
listen i don't we've discussed this at
length and we can't figure this question
out and it may sound like we're dodging
but we honestly have no idea who the
next actor or we would want an an actor
to pl to do another version where they
play nic cage
that would be the daniel day-lewis as
nick cage yes that's true christian bale
and full prosthetics playing nick cage
playing himself i would watch that yeah
i'd watch that
you